one of the items that came out on
Thursday night why Thursday night why
not Thursday afternoon carson wentz got
a new deal with the philadelphia eagles
we didn't get a chance to talk about it
Friday because we weren't on TV now I
talked about it at length on Pro
Football Talk live radio only and
there's a lot of different ways this one
goes Chris but just give me the since
since you weren't around on Friday and I
didn't even bother to try to get you out
of bed and get you to call in and share
your thoughts on the Wentz contract your
first reaction when you saw for year 128
million dollar extension for Carson
Wentz after three NFL seasons two of
which resulted in season-ending injuries
in December yeah well I went Wow I went
Wow I went to extension I looked at it
and I said wow this was brilliant by
both sides I think that's what I looked
at more than I think Mike I'm a Carson
Wentz fan you know that I building him
I've seen enough to go the guy's got
special talent as far as you know
running in the pocket being able to
break tackles being running out of the
pocket I should say making big-time
throws who got a great arm got a great
deep ball he has shown the ability to
carry a team when the team is not
playing all that well he's that type of
talent and I just think it was it was
deal that made sense to me Mike as far
as the guaranteed money or at least what
we see it as as right now was player
friendly that way but the total the
totality of the extension was very team
friendly and that's where I liked it and
I just thought it was a great move by
the Philadelphia Eagles and Carson Wentz
not trying to be too greedy at this
point and realizing he's been injured
and this is a smart move for him too but
there's nothing wrong with being greedy
again I struggle with this all the time
yeah you are you are putting your body
at sacrifice for short-term significant
injury long-term chronic cognitive and
orthopedic injury you get what you can
get what you can while you can Chris
we've talked about this before too many
of these teams don't even spend up to
the salary cap they have a budget in
place that is below the absolute
spending limit you only have to spend 89
cents per dollar on a four year rolling
average so there are teams that are just
taking money that could go to players
and cramming it into their coffers when
you have a team at the bargaining table
get what you can while you can
understand from Carson Wentz the
standpoint there's
reason to take the bird in the hand and
you can say all you want about what you
want right you can be rattling off
things you want like Spalding and
Caddyshack I think I use that line on
Friday but it was only on Radio use it
again you can say what you want but when
they put an offer on the table you can't
refuse that changes everything when
you're Carson Wentz and you look at in
Sam do to make four million this year
twenty two point seven million next year
and they're offering me guarantees that
exceed one hundred million dollars total
and I know that I could get injured
again yeah this is a pretty good deal
for me I can't say no to it even though
maybe I would like to get more yeah
right yeah you know exactly you know and
a guy that you know saw how quickly life
can change I tore my ACL in a year I'm
about to be the MVP I got 34 touchdowns
seven interceptions
here he goes last year he thinks okay
here we are I'm finally starting back
for the the Philadelphia Eagles I seem
healthy everything's good oh gosh got a
little back problem so he understands
how quickly life can change in the NFL
from that standpoint and you're right
once that money got dangled out in front
of him and he realized gosh it could be
one play again and I could be you know
done for a year or two and and going
through struggles Ville as far as
rehabbing trying to get healthy so it
makes sense from both sides it really
does and I thought it was a brilliant
move by the Philadelphia Eagles they're
sold on their guy they've never really
wavered on that from get-go you hear
comments from Doug Peterson people on
the team it seems like they believe in
Carson Wentz and I believe they should I
know Nick Foles came in and did a lot of
good things but I don't think Nick Foles
is nearly as talented as Carson Wentz
and it sounds like Carson Wentz is
hopefully fixing some of the off the
field locker room attitude things that
team the player study was entitled with
if he does that he's really kind of the
perfect type of quarterback yeah I agree
with you completely and the thing that
was odd about this when you look at new
money and there's two different ways to
analyze these deals now agents want to
only focus on the new money average
because it makes the deal look better
Carson Wentz's new money average is 32
million per year that puts him at fourth
among all quarterbacks but when you look
at the total value at signing yeah he's
at twenty five and a half million he's
behind the likes of Jimmy Garoppolo
whose total value at signing was twenty
seven and a half million Kirk Cousins
twenty eight million total value at
signing so it's it is kind of a win-win
in that respect but I'll tell you what
the
here's the big criticism I have the
Carson Wentz contract he's committed
through 2024 Chris and between now and
then new CBA is coming yeah new TV deals
are coming gambling revenue is going to
begin to pour through the cash register
for the NFL the salary cap is going to
keep going up and Carson Wentz is gonna
find himself two or three years from now
saying this really isn't that good of a
deal and that was the old school Eagles
approach I remember they did this to
guys like Shawn Andrews and Mike
Patterson when Joe Boehner was running
the team dangled a big contract with a
long term component to it right and
they're gonna be happy for the first two
or three years and then eventually
they're gonna look around and say man
I'm getting screwed here
yeah that could happen to Carson Wentz
in a few years could happen but I think
all sides will be happy if we get three
years four years down the road and we go
oh okay
Carson Wentz has been consistently one
of the best quarterbacks in football
over these three or four years and we're
going deep into the playoffs you know a
number of those years as well they're
not gonna be mad when Carson Wentz goes
okay guys yeah I need a new deal I'm way
below market value
I was nice the first time around now we
need to bump up I don't think if that
comes to that conversation I think both
sides will be happy to do it because
they're gonna go know you've been
playing that well you're right you're a
guy you showed you're healthy and I
don't think there'll be any issues with
that and they'll deal with it when the
time comes once you put your name to
that contract commit you through 2024
you're taking a leap of faith you are
they're going to honor it because they
don't have to honor if they can hold
firm we talked last hour about the Rams
and Jared Goff he was the first pick in
2016 Wentz was the second pick CEO Oh
Kevin dumb-off made it clear on Friday
the Rams are operating on a different
timetable so I think they're gonna wait
one more year we'll get to golf I want
to go to dak Prescott because he is the
guy who is currently on deck this is it
this is the hit we thought he'd get a
contract before Carson Wentz because he
was drafted in 2016 but he wasn't a
first-round pick so this is it for the
Cowboys contract year next year free
agency or franchise tag most likely
franchise tag barring a long-term deal
and Chris I don't know whether this
helps or hurt but the once deal
complicates things right for Prescott
because I'll tell you
what you look at 32 million new money
per year and you look at what Carson
Wentz's accomplished and you look at
what Prescott's accomplished and you can
make a hell of an argument that Prescott
deserves as much or more he's been
healthy for three straight years
forty-eight regular-season appearances
two playoff appearances a playoff win
he's actually played in January unlike
Wentz right there's something to be said
for that and if I'm arguing on behalf of
dak Prescott I can say hey I want at
least thirty two million per year in new
money I think that's the argument you
know the only you know and and I don't
think Dallas can make the
counter-argument to go no well we think
Carson Wentz is better than you dak
Prescott I don't think they can make
that counter argument and not ruffle
some feathers there with the dak
Prescott camp even though I think the
high end of Carson Wentz is better than
the high end of a a DAC Prescott and I
think we've seen that to a degree but I
agree with you
this is two out of three years in his
career it's the playoffs got his first
playoff win this year you know the first
time around three years ago they were
the number one seed in our number two
seed and had a first-round bye and lost
to Aaron Rodgers so I think you know
ultimately what this will set up and I
don't know but it's I think he's just
gonna outdo a Carson Wentz I think you
know he'll be able to say okay I'm gonna
outdo them and the new money as far as
32 million per year maybe he gets thirty
two and a half somewhere in that range
right around there and then as far as
just the the total average salary as far
as the extension is concerned I think
he'll out do a Carson Wentz there who
what do we save is that 25 - I would see
dak Prescott maybe being around 26 26
and a half and then maybe both sides can
be happy there and and you you're
touching on a key point here we talked
earlier about that new money average and
how agents love to push new money
because it makes the deals look better
yeah I think the teams at a certain
level like to focus on new money when
you're dealing with a guy especially a
dak Prescott who has one year left on
his contract had only two million
dollars because here's the and here's
how striking of a difference it is if
you give dak Prescott the same deal that
the Eagles gave to Carson Wentz for
years 1:28 thirty two million per year
in new money you add that to the one
year that he's
left at 2 million it's five years 130
that's 26 million at signing
that's a five-year deal Chris worth less
than Jimmy Garoppolo that say hello my
mic as soon as I set it out of my mouth
I said you know what the problem here is
is Jimmy Garoppolo is the problem in
this conversation
he was overpaid that's the first thing
we got to say you're right and dak
Prescott could definitely sit there and
go no I deserve more than Jimmy
Garoppolo and I'll sit here in dak
Prescott corner and go yes he does he's
proven he deserves it no matter what we
think Jimmy Garoppolo can be or might be
he's not there yet and he wasn't there
when he signed the contract to where dak
Prescott is right now and I know now
that I'm thinking about that aspect if
you're right it's gonna be hard for him
to accept less money than a Jimmy
Garoppolo as far as that average salary
is concerned yeah that is going to be
the challenge and there's been some
indications that the cowboys and dak
Prescott are far apart and it may just
be that Prescott has to do what Kirk
Cousins did play out the rookie contract
get franchise tagged once try to
negotiate a long-term deal based on that
franchise tag it'll be in the
neighborhood of 25 or 26 million for dak
Prescott for next year unless the
Cowboys go exclusive franchise tag which
I guess is possible I don't want to go
too far down this rabbit hole Chris but
if they would use the non-exclusive
franchise tag on dak Prescott could you
see a team try to sign and do an offer
sheet and give up two first-round picks
I don't think so
I don't I mean as much as I like dak
Prescott and I'd be happy and I'm happy
for him to be the quarterback of my
franchise and be the leader that way you
know I don't know if he's the
transcendent type talent to where you go
okay we'll give away two first-round
picks and give you money that's gonna
make you you know in that type of
scenario you know one of the the
highest-paid quarterbacks in the NFL and
another reason to not do it there are so
many young quarterbacks that are panning
out now you know education used to be if
you ever had a chance to give up two
first-round quarterbacks for a
quarterback a franchise quarterback to
first round picks rather you did it
because you're using that extra
first-round pick as insurance that the
first pick is getting you a great
quarterback because it's a crapshoot at
least it used to be it's less of a
crapshoot so I'd rather hold on to
those two first-round draft picks and
take my chances with a young quarterback
especially because that young
quarterback is going to cost you a lot
less money on that first contract which
the Cowboys have benefited from
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports